بعد دعوته الى انهاء العمل بالدستور
لاعادته الى السلطه الرئيس السابق هو
دونالد ترامب يتراجع قائلا ان الاخبار
الزائفه تحاول اقناع الامريكيين بانه دعا
الى ذلك مؤكدا انه لا يريد الغاء الدستور
تراجع ترامب جاء بعد سيل انتقادات
فالنائبه الجمهوريه
الدستور فيما اعتبرت السيناتور الجمهوريه
لزمالكاويسكي الدعوه اهانه للجمهوريين اما
مستشاره السابق للامن القومي فدع
المحافظين الى معارضه حملته للانتخابات
الرئاسيه
مستعد لرئيس يرفض الدستور بشكل قاطع هناك
الكثير ممن يتلاعبون بالقواعد بما في ذلك
الرئيس ايضا لكن اقتراح الرئيس ترامب
بالغاء الدستور بحيث يمكن اعادته الى
منصبه هو حقا خارج نطاق ما يجده معظم
الناخبين مقبولا
البيت الابيض بدوري يعتبر تصريحات ترامب
لا نعرف الامه الامريكيه فيما حضر زعيم
الديمقراطيين في مجلس الشيوخ شكشوما ترامب
خارج عن السيطره ويشكل خطرا على
الديمقراطيه داعيا الجميع الى ادانت هجومه
الديمقراطيون يفهمون بان دونالد ترامب هو
اداه تنظيم رائعه لحزبهم لقد كان كارثيا
على الجمهوريين في الانتخابات وهكذا فان
الديمقراطيين سعداء جدا بان دونالد ترامب
يقول اشياء سخيفه
ايلون ماسك الذي ساهم الى حد ما بمنشور
ترامب بعد اصدار تويتر ملفات تكشف عن
التسكتور على تقرير حول نجل الرئيس جوبيدا
انتقد دعوه ترامب قائلا ان الدستور اكبر
من اي رئيس
رغم تاكيد ترامب انه لا يريد الغاء
الدستور واتهامه وسائل الاعلام بمحاوله
اقناع الامريكيين بذلك يصرخ خبراء ان عليه
ان يوضح ويشرح ما كان يقصده بدلا من ان
يقول ببساطه انك كلامه تم نقله بشكل خاطئ
حسين الطاوض العربيه